oh that'd be cool i can't i personally
love the idea of humans stepping on mars
i'm such a sucker for the romantic
notion of that
and being able to take pictures from
mars
so you would go i have
i uh yeah i would be what did you say
you said
you wouldn't be not in the first 10 000.
which it's funny because to me that's
that's brave to be in the first million
i think when the declaration of
independence was signed
in the united states that was like 2
million people
so i would like to show up when they're
signing those documents
okay so maybe the 2 million oh that's an
interesting way to think about it
because like then we're like
participating as citizenry and defining
the direction so it's not the technical
risk you just don't want to show up
somewhere that's
like america before yeah
because it's i i from a psychological
perspective
it's just gonna be a stressful mess as
people have
studied right it's like it's people uh
most likely
the process of colonization like
looks like basically a prison like
you're in a
very tight enclosed space with people
and it's just a really stressful
environment
you know how do you select the kind of
people that will go and then there will
be drama there's always trauma
and i just want to show up when there's
some rules
but you know it depends so i'm not
worried about the health and the
technical difficulties
i'm more worried about the psychological
difficulties
and also just not being able to tweet
like what are you gonna how are you
there's no netflix so yeah maybe
not in the first
million but the first hundred uh
thousand it's exciting to define the
direction
of a new like how often do we not just
have a
revolution to redefine our government as
you know smaller countries
are still doing to this day but
literally start over from scratch
there's uh just our financial system it
could be like
based on cryptocurrency you could think
about like
how democrat you know we have we have
now
the technology that can enable pure
democracy for example
if we choose to do that yeah as opposed
to representative democracy all those
kinds of things
you